how close are we then take well I know
I'm gonna get called out for saying this
but we're getting close and all you have
to do is look at who's there in the room
because we have the Iranian presidents
brother first off the Iranian Foreign
Minister the Iranian presidents brother
was a close aide in addition that we
have the head of the nuclear program we
had to have the head of the global
watchdog which is a very acrimonious
relationship with the Iranians right now
so that means they're getting into the
real nitty-gritty of exactly how
verification is going to work you
mentioned the russian foreign minister's
comments the fact that he says only
procedural issues remain is important a
month ago i sat down with him and to be
honest he was a bit skeptical that we
were going to actually get a deal now
everybody's saying July seventh when you
take a deadline of june thirtieth and
you change it to the next tuesday july
the seventh if you don't need it you
look really stupid right it's okay if
you move a deadline back six you sound
like you speak from experience yes I've
done it a couple of times myself so we
seem to be getting there right the
Devils in the details but think about
this the most important individual for
all of the negotiations is a Supreme
Leader of Iran and he tweeted a picture
of the negotiators today calling the
brave men that are trustworthy and that
is a sign of support because at the end
of the day what he decides is what
really matters and if he's doing that
people are now speculating that means
he's behind this process and come next
Tuesday we will have a deal so that the
United States Congress can actually play
with it for a little while but in the
end not getting away of it and bless it
and Brian just briefly where does this
leave us on the oil process so you know
Iranian oil is important the Iranians
have about 19 million barrels that's
about a quarter of global can daily
consumption sitting on nine ships off
their coast so that'll go to see as soon
as the deal is ver the deal is verified
sign and then six months later let's say
everybody says okay yeah you're playing
ball so that will go out to sea and go
to market then it'll take awhile to
ratchet up production it's more of a
2016 story but if you look at what's
moving the price of oil right now has
nothing to do with Iran and has
everything to do with a rock last month
Iraq alone increased production by about
half a million barrels that's almost as
much as the Iranians maybe we'll bring
to the market someday and they did it in
one month record production coming out
of Iraq you look at all of OPEC we're
just half a million barrels off of
record production OPEC is pumping like
there's no
tomorrow and then in the United States
the big number you want to watch today
is inventories that's where we learn
exactly how much oil they have on tap
there how much of a glut we still have
now yesterday we had a survey out saying
that week on week the amount of oil the
United States was going to drop then API
which is an industry body for the oil
and gas industry came out wit and said
actually we expect it to increase so
we'll see what happens when we get the
numbers today from the the statistical
department of the department of energy
but very important it doesn't look like
the glut of oil that's sitting in the
world's largest consumer yeah is
actually decreasing and that means
prices aren't going to go high anytime
soon